welcome to today's afternoon session uh
we will have uh in this session super
thick chakraborty who will tell us about
the knowledge compilation for synthesis
and uh
thanks everybody for coming for this
session so
I'm going to talk about uh primarily the
synthesis problem and the role of
knowledge compilation in that
I'm going to Define these terms uh and
we'll also see that you know
quantification is an essential step in
that process so as a byproduct we get
knowledge compilation for quantification
okay so here is a toy synthesis problem
uh let's say I'm trying to design uh
memoryless Arbiter yesterday Ryan I
talked about an Arbiter with temporal
logic specification so let's say this is
just memoryless so at every point it
receives at every time instant it
receives one of three requests let's say
these are Boolean variables and it has
to give one of three grams
uh and the properties that we want are
of course we want Mutual exclusion so no
two grants must be asserted at the same
time
uh we would like the our writer to be
responsive which means that if somebody
has requested it should not deny the
grant to everybody at least somebody
should be granted
and uh I think it's reasonable to expect
that the Arbiters should Grant only if
it is asked which means that if
it is granted to user one then user one
had requested and it is going to use a
two and use it two had requested and so
on
and all of this is just uh at every time
point it receives these and it's
supposed to generate
G1 G2 G3 which satisfies this so there
is no memory in it there is no temporal
aspect of it
so uh our job is now to synthesize uh G1
G2 G3 as Boolean functions of R1 R2 R3
such that these specifications
and these these formulas are always
satisfied now note that these formulas
actually do not tell us what is our what
is G1 in terms of R1 R2 R3 or what is G2
in terms of R1 R2 R3
they just tell us some relation between
uh the requests and the grants so that's
why such specifications are also called
relational specifications but the
synthesis task is to you know derive
functions out of these specifications
such that the specifications are
satisfied
so of course you know one can look at
the specifications for some time and
come up with you know Simple Solutions
for example one might say that okay if
if request 1 is there I'm going to Grant
one and if request one is not there but
request two is there I'm going to run 2
and neither request one or request two
are there but request 3 is there I'm
going to Grant 3 which would be kind of
prioritizing uh between the three users
uh and sure that is that is one way of
synthesizing the functions but it turns
out that
the space of solutions which means the
space of functions that one can write in
terms of R1 R2 R3 which satisfy these
specifications is actually quite diverse
and Rich and here I'm just going to show
you some of them which are completely
different from each other uh so here is
the first one that I said that if
request one comes Grant one otherwise
there's no request one but request to
Grant two and similarly for Grant three
here is another solution you know looks
very different from the previous one in
fact you know there's no permutation of
the indices of the first solution which
will give you the second solution but
you see that uh you know Grant three has
a similar kind of behavior but these
have very different behavior and here is
a third solution which is different from
the first two again
and no permutation of indices will give
you the third from the first two uh and
here you see that this solution looks
somewhat like this this also looks
somewhat like this but both of them are
present and this looks somewhat like
this coming from a different solution so
there is a rich space of things and of
course if one permutes the indices one
can always you know multiply each
Solution by six
so uh the question is that
existing synthesis tools which can solve
these kinds of problems they will take a
specification like this and they will
output one of these
Solutions
which the tool thinks is the best
for you I mean you don't have any
further control over it I mean uh Rana
talked about yesterday about soft
constraints and hard constraints but
really even among the solution space for
soft constraints and hard constraints
they can give very rich diversity
and so if you have a tool which just
takes the specification and output
something uh one actually doesn't get to
see this this entire space of solutions
and perhaps
use further uh you know optimization
criteria to choose among them
okay so if I were to abstract this
problem what we had was a vector of
Boolean variables which I'll call as
inputs which were the requests and there
was a vector of Boolean output variables
which were the grants
and then I had a formula Phi which was
the relational specification
and I was trying to synthesize functions
for each of these outputs such that for
every input when I replace the outputs
with these functions the specification
evaluates to true this is at an abstract
level what I was trying to do
uh and this is all good as as long as we
know that for every X there is some
value for Y which will make Phi true
then one can indeed ask uh you know give
me at least one such set of Y for every
X
but what happens if uh there are some
x's for which no y's are going to work
to make the specification true
so it is not the case that for every X
there exists of Y such that the
specification evaluates to true and such
kinds of specifications are also called
unrealizable Rana mentioned about this
yesterday uh and we want to ask is
synthesis still meaningful for such
specifications in the literature uh
actually these specifications are kind
of wished away mostly but of course
yesterday we heard that one can talk
about uh you know the best one can do
about such specifications so I'm going
to argue that there are actually fairly
interesting problems synthesis problems
whose specifications look like this I
mean it's not the case that for every x
one can find a y but uh
whenever one can find it's very
interesting to find those
okay so so as long as there is some X
for which I can find a y I think this
problem is the second bullet point is
that a for all y Theta is that a for all
X for all y or is that actually a or an
exist X for all y this one yeah is that
actually supposed to be for all y exist
for all X exists why yeah it's for so it
is not the case that for every X there
exists a y which means that there are
some X for which there exists no y got
it right
and and here is a very uh very nice
example of this uh
which is let's say my input is a twin
bit unsigned integer
and I have two outputs Each of which are
n bit unsigned integers
and here's my specification so I've
written it here with some abuse of
notation you know
but I I hope all of us understand and it
certainly can be written uh using a
Boolean formula of size of N squared so
I want to say x which is the input is
going to be the product of the outputs
integer multiplication
and none of the output should represent
the number one in n Bits these are
unsigned integers
right so if you stare at this
specification for uh a second you'll
realize what I'm asking is a non-trivial
factorization of a two n bit integer
okay so this is my specification and the
indeed you know even if I do the
simplest way of representing
multiplication as you know High School
multiplication algorithm this can be
represented by a Boolean formula of
cyber most of N squared and now if I ask
you that synthesize the outputs as
functions of the inputs I'm basically
asking you for a factorization circuit
okay
and note that uh you know I've specified
the N over here so it could very well be
the case that these functions for a
certain value of n Loop something and
for another value of n may be they look
different so this is really asking for a
non-uniform uh Circuit Family for
for factorization and you know I mean
this immediately tells us that the
synthesis problem in general is going to
be hard because I can write the
specification compactly but then we
don't even know it's open whether we can
do factorization even in the non-uniform
setting in polynomials
services
prime numbers yeah
but that doesn't give me like if if n is
uh it is two I could give it the input
seven
um and and that and and it'd be
impossible to meet the specification oh
yes yes absolutely uh so that's where
I'm coming to saying that this is in the
classical cells sense not a realizable
specification because there are some
inputs for which there won't be any
outputs
and yet this is uh an interesting
synthesis problem because it's
interesting yeah because uh
whenever I give you a number which is
not a prime
I would like to get non-trivial factors
so that's another another condition you
allow it to fail
yeah if if there is no okay exactly
exactly so so if there is uh
if for a given X there is no Y which
will work then actually any Y is as good
or as bad because everything is going to
fail
but for those X's for which there exists
a y I would like to get the right Y and
interestingly you know following up on
your question that uh yeah so for
non-primex we we get non-trivial factors
and if I am able to actually synthesize
these functions I can just plug it
inside this and I get a primality check
right
so uh so even specifications which do
not
are not realizable in the classical
sense which means for some inputs there
are no outputs which are going to work
uh the synthesis problem for them uh is
still interesting because uh I think
this is one certainly one
important example
so this sort of leads to this problem
which is called Boolean functional
synthesis where we're trying to design a
system which has some Boolean inputs
some Boolean outputs and there's a
relational specification
and our goal is to synthesize the
outputs as functions of the inputs such
that it satisfies the specification
whenever possible
and this can be formally written as that
for every X as long as there is a y
which satisfies this I would like the
synthesized functions to satisfy this
now of course so if there is no y then
whatever function I put here both of
them will evaluate performs
so uh such functions are also called
scholar functions in the literature for
y in terms of X in the formula Phi and
so we're basically doing booleans column
function synthesis here
so this is the problem statement this is
what we want to do we want to
synthesize these scolable functions
so this problem has a story in history
of course column functions occupy a very
important
position and first order logic where we
are basically trading off quantifiers
for function symbols
and seminal work by throw ups column
1920s and Jake her brand from 1930s
however the treatment here is more on
the
existence of these functions and to use
these functions to prove very powerful
results but not on how to synthesize
these functions given a formula how do I
get this cooling function and we know
that there's this column function it has
certain properties uh you know preserves
satisfiability once you substitute and
all of that
uh we can trace even further back and uh
you know George boole and later lowenham
uh they had considered this problem of
Boolean unification which is taken to
Boolean formulas and trying to
substitute uh
you know Boolean terms for Boolean
functions for variables over there such
that the two formulas become equivalent
and uh I mean Boolean unification has
connections to the problem that we're
talking about the schooling function
synthesis so interestingly you know this
this problem was looked at even before
to talk about school and functions
okay uh and uh you know I I just showed
some simple examples there turns out
that there are a lot of other
applications this is certainly not an
exhaustive list nor is the set of
citations exhaustive this is useful in a
repair of circuits and program synthesis
certifying QB of sat solvers disjunctive
decomposition of transition systems so a
whole bunch of other things
and uh of course you know people have
worked on this and uh there are several
approaches that that have been used uh
so in recent times uh for for realizable
specifications when you know that for
Alex there exists why Phi of XY is true
one can look at the proof of that and
extract
swollen functions out of it
uh there is something related to
iterated function composition which
doesn't scale very much it blows up very
fast uh there is bdd based and I'm going
to talk about it uh briefly uh because
it's kind of uh you know one of the
knowledge compiled forms from which you
can do efficient synthesis I'm going to
focus more on this which is uh trying to
come up with a new normal form for uh
Boolean functions which allow efficient
synthesis and then there are other
techniques like incremental
determinization input output separation
guest Check and repair all of these are
for synthesizing the function
synthesizing one set of functions from
the given specification
as I said the focus of this stock is
slightly different because we not only
want to synthesize a function but we
want to have a form where all the
functions can be synthesized efficiently
the entire space of functions is kind of
easily accessible and can be synthesized
so uh so so that's that's where we are
so you know the immediate question that
comes to mind is that how hard is it
going to be
uh and of course you know from the
factorization example we know that it's
not going to be easy but uh the answer
to this question is quite nuanced in the
sense that it depends on how you
represent Phi and how you represent this
column functions
and we will see that uh there are very
interesting connections uh about how how
you can change the representation of Phi
to make this problem simpler or for
other representations it might become
harder
okay so so let's look at the most
relaxed representation which means I'm
not putting any constraints on how you
want to be present so these are just
Boolean circuits suffice the Boolean
circuit and let's say my scholar
functions I'm also okay having those
Boolean circuits no other property
required of those
uh
it's not very hard to see that this
ought to be NP hard uh it's interesting
that uh actually you know not very
surprising again uh that even if you
allow exponential time you can't avoid
uh
large sized scholar functions so there
are problem instances where even if you
went and tried to solve this problem
using exponential time the smallest
column function that you can synthesize
is still going to be large
size
yes so so you can think of this uh
so here these y's are the outputs and
x's and the inputs
right so suppose it didn't have any
inputs
and I had only outputs
so in that period I'm asking can you
give me constant functions which will
make the specification true
so with special paint supplements solve
the position
yeah so uh
yeah so in terms of that you know under
these complexity theoretic uh
assumptions that the polynomial
hierarchy doesn't collapse we we will
always have specifications where the
smallest column function will be super
polynomial and if non-uniform
exponential time hypothesis fails the
non-uniform is because you know I mean
we
allowing the circuits to change as we go
from one end to another end then the
worst case column function I mean these
are not surprising but uh I mean that's
what we know if we have the most relaxed
representation so it's unlikely that
we'll have efficient algorithms over
here
so let's look at the other end of the
spectrum and let's say I have a very
constrained representation and uh Randy
Brandt uh you know talked about bdds and
other speakers have also talked about
bdds so if you use bdds
uh and actually even a more constrained
kind of bdd is called input first bdds
input first robds which means that all
the input variables X are ordered before
the output variables y
and they can be ordered between
themselves in whatever way but all the
input variables must appear before the
output variables so this is you know an
example of ability representing such a
specification
uh then it turns out that uh and if you
want the outputs also as
Rob reduce so this is kind of
constraining how the input specification
is going to be represented and also how
the output specif also the output
functions are going to be represented
uh so if this is your setting then it
turns out that you can do it in
polynomial time and it's actually very
simple to see how you can do it so I'm
going to illustrate right here on this
example so so in this example uh these
are the inputs the X's are the inputs
and the Y's at the outputs and uh the
solid edges are the one true edges the
dashed edges at the false edges
and so what you can see is that uh
you know at and I know that all the
inputs appear before all the outputs so
I I go to the first node uh you know
sort of I look at this level where the
outputs are first starting to appear
and at this node I ask is there a path
to the one leaf and if there is a path
to the one leaf it means that I can set
the outputs to values in this case one
and one which will make the
specification true
right so whenever I have this input I
can set the outputs to one and one to
make it true uh whenever I reach here
which could be either like this or like
this I can set the outputs to Y2 is 0 y
1 is 1 or Y2 is one
y1 is 0 and I'll satisfy the output I'll
satisfy the specification and here I
guess if I set both of these to 0 I'll
status right so if I give you this bdd
it's uh kind of trivial to come up with
constants at each of these nodes and
then this now gives from here you can
construct a bdd for Y2 and for y1
because no
basically you have
a decision diagram which is probably not
reduced but then you can apply the usual
bdd
you know
the usual way to reduce the bdd nodes
from non-bd structures and this will
immediately give you uh beads for both y
two and y1 and once again you can see
here that there are multiple there are
multiple ways in which you could have
satisfied the specification at this
point you could have chosen y 2 0 y 1 is
1 or vice versa and so bdd actually
exposes this whole thing I mean once I
give you the representation is a bdd
it's out there you know what what the
difference what the difference colon
functions can be and how you want to get
them
so
so so the question we want to ask is
that uh but of course you know bdds have
their own problems we know that they're
very order dependent on the variables
they can blow up
so we ask that do we really need uh you
know input first Robbies to have
polynomial time synthesis
and the answer to that is no uh and in
fact I'm going to talk about a much
weaker form than robd exponentially more
succinct than robds which we call
synthesis negation normal form and this
is going to yield polytime algorithms
for synthesis uh as long as this column
functions are represented as Boolean
circuits and remember here in this case
this column functions were also
represented as Robbins
but here as long as we are fine with
this column functions is Boolean
circuits I can do with exponentially
more succinct representations of the
specification
and uh yeah maybe this picture will come
to later uh this is like really saying
that I mean I showed you how from
ability you can get the scrolling
functions this is really showing how
from a synonym specification you can
you know put some M copies of these if
there are M outputs and then you can get
this colon functions but but we'll get
to this later
okay so so we've already seen that uh
from input first Robbies if I want the
scolium so so this is the representation
of the specification and this is the
representation of this column function
from input first robds if I want the
scoring functions to be synthesized as
robds I can do in polynomial time
uh
if I have nnf circuits and if I want
this if I have a nnp circuit
representing the specification and I
want this column function as in the
circuits uh it's so these dotted lines
means these are conditional con
exponential bounds there are complexity
theoretic conjectures as I showed
earlier
so this is kind of uh the map that we
have uh
it says that the complexity of synthesis
really depends on what is this
representation for the specification and
representation for this column function
that you're choosing right so for
example
from Rob reduce to nnf I can do
polynomial uh but from rotds to robds I
I mean the best we know is exponential
and we don't
have a bit of bound over there but from
input first rotd we can get to nnx
circuits in polynomial and also to our
OBD it is polynomial and of course here
uh you know the this column functions uh
they're they're just uh I mean they only
have the inputs in them right the
scoring functions are expressed only in
terms of the inputs so an robd is the
same as input first probabilities in the
specification you have inputs and
outputs this colon functions you have
only inputs so this is the kind of map
that we have and of course uh if one
looks at other representations which
have been talked about over the last few
days like uh decomposable negation
normal form
um
then
this
this joint what is that leaf work
deterministic decomposable negation
normal form and other kinds of things so
these can all be located in this map I
have just shown here a small sampling of
it
uh and this also kind of motivates the
study of the synonym and its cousins and
that's what we're going to do now okay
so uh to begin with uh I'll present a
very simplified view of synthesis and uh
you know I guess this will drive what we
what are the features what are the
properties that we need in this uh form
that we want to use for synthesis
so suppose uh suppose I had a one output
specification so this just had one
output and whatever some bunch of inputs
and let's say this big rectangle here
denotes the set of all possible
assignments to x to the inputs
so you can divide this space into four
parts uh depending on whether
Phi of x one is true or false and Phi of
x 0 is true or false okay
and once I do this Division I guess it's
not hard to see that in in this quadrant
uh every scolum function must evaluate
to true because if I put 0 here the
specification is falsified and similarly
this quadrant every scoring function
must evaluate to zero because if I put
one here the specification is falsified
but in these two colored quadrants uh
here no matter what you what this column
function evaluates to the specification
is satisfied here no matter what it
evaluates to the specification is
falsified
so we are free to choose uh
what f1x should evaluate to in these two
quadrants but in these two things every
scoring function must evaluate to zero
in every scrolling function is divided
to
so this shows that you know although
there is a diversity of scolium
functions like I showed in my first
slide uh there are some common
properties among them there are some
inputs on which all of them must agree
and then there is some room to play
around over here
and uh so you know if I ask so what is a
fun x so there are many possibilities I
could just say Phi X1 uh I guess that
would amount to choosing this to be one
and this to be zero so whenever Phi x 1
is true F1 X is true I could have
negation Phi x 0 which is uh probably
choosing this to be 0
so that whenever Phi x 0 is true uh it
evaluates to false
um
uh and similarly I could have many other
things and interestingly this picture
also tells us that the number of choices
is exactly the number of ways in which
you can assign uh
values to the function over here so the
number of satisfying assignments of Phi
X1 is equivalent to 5 x 0 so these are
the two things number of satisfying
assignments two raised to that
so even for a singles column function
the number of choices can be pretty
large
okay so one output synthesis was easy so
for multi-output synthesis we are just
going to
try to reduce it to one output synthesis
so we will first construct a new
specification which is for the time
being let's say we are somehow doing
this quantification we will see how to
do this quantification
so we have Quantified out all the output
variables other than one and that gives
us a new specification
and what's this telling you this is
giving you this is telling this is give
specifying a relation between X and Y M
such that whenever you satisfy the
specification you know that there is a
way to assign values to the other
outputs which will satisfy the overall
specification
so so that is nice because now I have
just a single output specification and I
know if I can
synthesize this output correctly there
is always a way to synthesize the other
outputs
so uh you know we we just synthesize
or ym we synthesize this column function
and then what we do is we then go and
try to construct a new specification
from this where we have Quantified out
all but the last two
and so this now has ym minus 1 and ym in
it but remember I have already found
this column function for ym
so I can just treat this as y minus 1 is
the only output X and Y M are the inputs
get this column function in terms of X
and Y M and because I have already found
out ym in terms of X I can substitute it
and get this going function for y minus
1 and I can keep repeatedly doing this
so this looks like a simple strategy to
to sort of address multiple outputs uh
there are a few important things here
one is that there is an ordering on the
outputs and I'm first trying to
synthesize the one output thing for y m
and then y minus 1 so looks like I have
already implicitly ordered the outputs
and there is this uh you know your
existential quantification that's
happening here which is uh we have to
figure out how to do that
and in fact this this sort of shows the
connection between uh synthesis and
existential quantification which is kind
of elucidated over here
that uh if I can do efficient
computation of this quantifier
elimination problem
right here I'm not so this is not a SAT
problem because I'm not eliminating all
the variables and coming up with the
true or false answer zero or one answer
so I'm eliminating part of them and I'm
eliminating them in a sequence
but if I can do efficient computation of
this from what I just said in the
previous slide uh it should be possible
for us to efficiently compute this colon
functions and note the other way around
is kind of trivial because if I can
compute this column functions I can just
substitute this column functions and
Achieve extension quantification so this
is a very strong connection between the
two uh you know if I can have a
representation that enables sufficient
quantification then
this representation will also enable
efficient synthesis and therefore uh you
know this motivates us to ask that what
would be such representations which will
uh enable efficient quantification but
remember we we don't want to quantify
things some arbitrary subset of
variables I mean we we are saying that
there is an order and we want to
quantify it in that order so as long as
that is enabled as long as that is uh
doable efficiently you know in terms of
the representation size we are doing
fine but remember the the lower bounds
that we talked about so even if we find
such a representation we know that
compiling to this representation it will
be inefficient in the worst case right
because there are at least conditional
lower bounds
okay
so uh so so therefore you know trying to
find a representation for efficient
synthesis is kind of equivalent to
trying to find a representation for
efficient quantification and vice versa
so this now motivates this thing about
given a specification how do I compile
it to a form from which I can do
efficient quantification and hence
efficient synthesis so this is the
Wikipedia definition of knowledge
compilation
so it's a family of approaches for
addressing the interactability of a
number of artificial intelligence
problems this is what Wikipedia says and
the propositional model is compiled in
an offline phase two of forms that
supports subsequent queries in
polynomial time
so in our so it looks something like
this for example you can have a formula
which could be a CNF formula or a
circuit and a compiler might compile it
down to a bdd or a dnnf and then in
polytime polynomial in the size of this
you can do lots of other things which
otherwise are hard so of course this
this compilation can be worst case
exponential we cannot avoid it given the
complexity of these problems
so in our context uh we would like the
knowledge compilation for synthesis to
be once again given a specification
which would be C in a formula or circuit
and then I also need to know what are
the inputs and what are the outputs just
the formula is not good enough
and then I I want to get some compiled
form here which we call the synthesis
negation normal form such that I can
then synthesize colon functions I can do
a sequence of quantifications quantifier
eliminations in polynomial time in the
size of this okay so this is the
knowledge compilation problem
for synthesis
okay so so let's see what's the problem
if I try to do existential
quantification with normal circuits
these are the most compact things that
one can think about no restrictions on
the circuits I mean negation normal form
every circuit can be converted to
negation normal form
linear blow up
every and or circuit
so so here is my specification Phi x y
and at the leaves here I have shown
these are the output variables y one
negation y one y and negation y n and
these are the inputs and if I were to do
uh usual existential quantification so I
will basically suppose I'm trying to
quantify out the variable y y1 I will
set y1 to 1.
right which means I will set these
leaves to 1 and those leaves to zero and
then I'll set y1 to 0 so setting these
Loops to 0 and these leaves to 1 and
then I would like to order them up so
that's the definition of existential
modification
problem with this is that there's a
potential doubling of sides happening
per for each variable that I'm
quantifying
so therefore uh we would like to see if
we can uh start off with such nnf
representations and convert them to some
other form which can
probably allow us to avoid this doubling
of size
so what is the this new form that well
it's not a new form it's just a
transformation and existential
quantification friendly representation
so what we do is we take the nnf uh
you know circuit is a dag let's say it's
like this all the negations are at the
leaves the inner nodes are only and the
nodes
and then uh we look at all the leads
which have the outputs negated and we
introduce uh new variables over there
which I call them
an over line or bar variables so earlier
I had negation y1 negation Y2 now I have
y1 bar and Y 2 bar and note that
you know if I look at the function
represented by this root uh this
function when I had negation y1 negation
Y2 is
semantically different from the function
when I replace these by y one bar y two
bar obviously because I've introduced
new variables and I've gotten rid of
some of the
literals that I had earlier so this we
call the positive form of the
specification and I can do it for
every output literal every negative
every negative output literally uh and
you can see that this is this is doable
very efficiently you can just replace
the literals have new variables over
there
so so why why are we talking about this
because these circuits have certain
interesting properties that first of all
for example they are monotone with
respect to all the Y I's and y i bars
right because it's nnf so there are no
negations inside and I've just removed
the negations from here
and we're going to use this monotonicity
uh what I'm going to show just now
so this was our picture earlier that we
had uh an nnf circuit
where I was setting the variable to 1
and 0 and now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take this positive form
where uh instead of Pi 1 and negation y1
there is y1 and Y Bar
and here I was setting them to 1 0 and 0
1 and here I'm going to set them both to
1 1 and because this circuit is monotone
I know that uh
you know this whatever function was
represented here must imply this and
similarly whatever function was
represented here must imply this follows
from the monotonicity of the circuit
here
and therefore uh if I order them up that
implication will also hold
and so this looks like uh a very cheap
way to get an over approximation of the
existentially Quantified formula
uh the question is uh we would like this
you know to be equivalent so what what
is the other thing that we need over
here such that the implication holds in
the other direction as well because if
it does then uh then we can effectively
replace this quantification by this okay
so so let's see uh you know I mean we
know that this exists y one Phi X Y was
already implying this Phi hat with y1
set to 1 and y y 1 bar set to one we
want to know when does this other
direction hold
so let's see uh so you know we can ask
when does the other direction not hold
and from there we'll get a condition of
when it holds
so this is if this does not hold it
means this side has to be true and that
side has to be false right that's the
only way that an implication does not
hold
so we must have this Phi hat with y1 and
y1 bar set to true as true and exists y1
Phi is false but exists y 1 5 if I just
expand it out in its definition it is 5
with Y one set one not five with five
instead of zero this has to be false uh
but then I also know that 5 and 1 5 with
Y one set to 1 is the same as Phi hat
with Y one is set to 1 and y one bar is
set to zero remember in Phi hat the
negation y ones were replaced by y one
bar so 5 with Y one set to 1 is the same
as Phi hat with Y one set to one and Y
one bar set to zero so if I want this or
this to be 0 then each of them
individually has to be 0 which means
that Phi hat with
y1 and Y 1 bar set to 1 0 must be 0 and
5 hat with instead to zero one must be
zero and because Phi hat is monotone uh
it also means that Phi hat with y1 and Y
1 bar both set to zero must be zero okay
so now if you look at this when y1 is 1
y y one bar is one
this function evaluates to True when y1
is 1 y 1 bar is 0 the function evaluates
to false 0 1 it evaluates to false and 0
0 it evaluates to false so what does it
look like it looks like
the and function
so it's basically uh you know this
implication does not hold exactly when
these conditions are satisfied but this
is exactly the same as saying can Phi
hat realize y1 and Y 1 bar which means
can I set values to the other variables
in Phi hat except the y1 and Y 1 bar
such that Phi hat becomes
equivalent to Y one y n y 1 and y one
but
so the Insight that we gained from here
is that uh if Phi hat cannot realize
this which is what we also called and
unrealizability
then we know that uh this implication
must hold and this implication in any
case holds then these two would be
semantically equivalent right so this
basically tells us that if I want to do
quantification efficiently without a
blow up remember Phi hat is linear in
the size of Phi
so if I want to do quantification
without a blow up in the size without a
doubling in the size uh then if I can
ensure that Phi hat cannot realize y1
and Y 1 bar then I can effectively do
that right so what does it mean I mean
how do I know whether Phi hat can
realize y1 and y1 bar like I mean b we
had some circuit for Phi hat over here
right how do I know whether this
realizes y1 and Y 1 bar so this turns
out to be a SAT call basically an unset
check
so we are asking that Phi hat with both
of them set to 1 is true and Phi hat
with one zero is false and zero one is
false so is this whole thing satisfiable
if this whole thing is satisfiable then
it can realize y1 and Y 1 bar if it is
unsatisfiable it cannot realize that
and this was for one variable and I can
now do this uh inductively for the other
variables because I'm quantifying them
in sequence right so if this holds for
this variable then I can get the result
of quantifying out y one by just doing
the substitution
and in that I can again check whether Y2
and Y2 bar is and unrealizable then I
can get the result of quantifying out Y2
and so on
okay
uh so uh so so basically this looks like
is a very crucial property that whatever
representation we have uh if I just add
the leaves replace the negation Wise by
one by y bars then I should not be able
to realize these ends so then uh you
know we can go and ask that what are the
normal forms in the literature that
enforce this and unrealizability
and it turns out that quite a few of
them already enforce and and
unrealizability so this is the
decomposable uh negation normal form uh
from Adnan Darwish and pierremarket so
they you know what what they say is that
the circuit should be such that
you can't have paths uh from
two different parts from the same
literal uh to an and gate or
parts from a literal and its negation to
an and gate so there's actually much
more than what we need all we needed is
we should not have Y and Y Bar I mean
they also disallow this but anyway this
is a sufficient condition right so if a
circuit is in if the specification is
already in decomposable negation normal
form it already satisfies the and
unrealizability condition so then this
is good so this is sufficient time for
polynomial time and space synthesis
uh we can weaken this by saying that
well all I require is that the Y and the
Y Bar should not meet up at a nand gate
there should be no topological paths
from Y and Y Bar meeting up at an and
gate and this is also sufficient because
this also ensures an unrealizability
and uh we can then generalize it even
further by saying that
uh let's look at the circuit and and
maybe it's okay to have such such ad
gaps inside the circuit but at the root
can I
realize y k and y k bar for
every y k in the order of in The
Ordering of the outputs right so this is
basically saying that uh
can I order the outputs and then for
each output can I ask whether I can
realize y k n y k bar over there when I
assign some kinds of values over here
and then you know one can work out the
conditions and then it suffices to
assign only once here
and allow all possible assignments here
right so so we have a linear ordering of
the outputs and then in this linearing
or linear ordering we just keep asking
this question that is there an
assignment here says that when you set
all ones here can this become y k and y
k bar if it can then it's violating the
and unrealizability condition so if it
cannot
it satisfies the hand and Railway
and and if this works for all of the
outputs then we say that it's in
synthesis negation normal form
and this also turns out to be a
sufficient condition
and uh interestingly uh
this condition is far more far weaker
than the condition that for example a
bdd ensures this dnnf ensures this uh
but this condition turns out to be far
weaker so much so that we can get
exponential gaps in the representation
size
so uh
so here is an example of synonym so here
is a Formula written down as an nnf
circuit and then uh let's
and and this representation is neither
in dnnf nor in w d n n f because you
have things like Y2 and negation Y2
going and meeting up at an and gate so
this is this doesn't satisfy any of the
uh forms that were there in the
literature earlier
uh but now if I can take the same
circuit and say that okay here is my
ordering of outputs and then I'm first
going to ask that
can I make this route behave like y1 and
Y 1 bar but there is no y 1 bar here so
there is no way of making it behave like
y1 and Y 1 bar so we are doing okay for
y1
but once I'm doing okay for y1 when I go
to check for Y2 I'm allowed to set y1 to
1 and then ask can I make this look like
Y2 and Y 2 bar
and now once again there is no way to
make it twice 1 by 2 bar although there
in the original circuit there was a path
from y to a negation Y2 but because of
this simplification it's now there's no
way to make it Y2 and Y 2 bar so this
representation isn't synonym with
respect to this ordering but then if you
flip the ordering then it is not because
uh
you know the I've asked Can I
can I make this behave like Y2 and Y to
bar and indeed there's a way of
assigning values to the other variables
it makes it Behavior required to invite
them
so uh so the same representation may be
incident with respect to one ordering of
outputs and not incident f with respect
to another ordering of outputs
and so so this definition is order
dependent one can also come up with an
order independent variant saying for all
ordering of the outputs it should be but
then that becomes much stronger
and uh here is kind of the succinctness
map for where synonym is with respect to
the other things uh
so uh not sure if the colors here are
showing up properly so we have an
unconditional uh exponential
succinctness of synonym with respect to
rubd doesn't depend on any complexity
theoretic conjectures and uh the the
other two which is uh
the exponential succinctness with
respect to uh deterministically
composable negation normal form is
conditioned on uh you know P naught
equal to vnp
and wdnnf and the weak dnnf and synonym
is conditioned on P naught not equal to
NP
and of course this was already shown
earlier that dnnf is
unconditionally exponentially more
succinct than RBD so what you see
looking at this picture is that uh this
form we have just seen suffices for
quantification in a in an given order
and therefore it suffices for synthesis
and it can be actually exponentially
more succinct than uh than several of
the other forms which also satisfy this
and unrealizability condition but can be
much larger
and uh here is how we you know finally
use this so suppose I have given you a
specification in synonym and then uh you
know the outputs are represented as y 1
bar Y2 bar
and then uh
you know there is a particular way of
fixing values to these outputs and
stringing them together that actually
gives you this column functions for y1
and Y2 so this is this is effectively we
are doing existential quantification by
setting both of these to one because
it's incident if this achieves
existential quantification and then we
are setting uh I mean remember there was
you know a lot of
possibilities for choosing a one outputs
column function and we are basically
choosing these one output scoring
functions here so we can show that if
this circuit uh if this representation
had size M then all this column
functions can be represented by a
circuit of size M times that
uh with at most order M squared
additional connections so if I have this
incident and if I can actually do
synthesis uh in polynomial time
starting from this internet
representation
but of course converting an arbitrary
specification to synonym
will incur
worst case exponential given the lower
bounds condition lower bounds
okay so uh given this uh you know we
actually have two algorithms for
compiling uh from actually arbitrary
circuits to could be CNF could be
arbitrary circuits to
um
so the first algorithm C2 Sim takes the
input as CNF and then uh it generates a
synonym out of it and this is really
some optimizations on top of the D4 Tool
uh where you know decomposition into
components with disjoint support is done
and we Branch only when and
unrealizability fails
and this is uh some another tool that we
have called the conflict
which can take an arbitrary Boolean
circuit as input converted to uh synonym
and it uses counter example guided
transformation to enforce and
unrealizability and this turns out to be
more powerful uh than than this uh
citizen Builds on top of D4 which
actually compiles to ddnnf
deterministically composable negation
normal form and uh because we know that
that's a much stronger form than what
synonym requires so it's not surprising
that the conflict achieves a better
performance
so this is uh you know some results some
benchmarks
uh maybe at this point so so I also had
some slides on uh
or maybe I'll just you know very quickly
go through this that you know we have
all seen sufficient conditions for
polynomial time synthesis
uh can we also get necessary conditions
and it turns out that
it is it is possible to do this so I
will not go into the technicalities of
it but it is a further uh you know
generalizing The Forbidden semantics of
sin and F saying that can we divide the
outputs into groups and then linearly
ordered the groups earlier we had
the outputs were linearly ordered now
the outputs are divided into groups and
their sort of partitioned into groups
the outputs of the leaves and then they
are linearly ordered and then after that
it is pretty much the same similar
condition like what we had put the nnf
for synonym and this turns out to be
both a sufficient and necessary
condition which is uh which means that
uh
so uh
which means that of course you know
every specification in this format can
be compiled it can be
transformed to scholar functions in
polynomial time but
every representation form which allows
like for example bdds or synonym for
whatever ddn and F every representation
form which allows compilation in
polynomial time which allows synthesis
in polynomial time can also be compiled
to this form in polynomial time so
therefore this is you know just
polynomial time away from any other
representation class which allows
efficient synthesis so that sense it's
also necessary
so and of course uh you know this also
enjoys some nice properties so I will
skip those in interest of time
and
yeah and then there is a a sort of
simple way of transforming a Class C of
efficiently synthesizable specifications
uh to this form by actually synthesis I
mean this is of course just an
existential proof this should not be the
actual compilation algorithm by saying
that if it is efficiently synthesizable
I can synthesize it and then I can use
this column functions to transform it
into this form
uh
and then I guess uh we also have a
compiler for compiling to this uh you
know more General necessary and
sufficient form
but uh that compiler is much less
efficient
so uh so to conclude uh you know we
talked about some new normal forms for
efficient Boolean functional synthesis
uh this allows quite efficient
compilation uh this is not so efficient
but this is a sufficient condition for
polynomial time synthesis this also
gives a necessary condition
um and as future work I mean we've heard
last few days even today a lot about
certification so uh how to certify these
compilation algorithms is interesting
and as I said right at the beginning
that these compilation algorithms are
not just giving you one skolin function
from a specification they're making
available the entire space of scolium
functions all of which can now be
efficiently synthesized
um
and of course yeah this fine-tuning and
all these are of course always to be
done
and then can we go beyond the Boolean
case can we do first order
specifications infrastructure logic some
restricted theories infrastructural
logic uh and then we use similar
representation forms to do efficient
synthesis
so that I'll end uh yeah the questions
yeah
[Applause]
I might have five questions I'll take
one of the Lord so uh so you say Bond so
something less than first order is just
finite domains
something less than less than first
order would be finite domains the Y
ranges
right right
does does the
so does your representation lend itself
to a finite domain version with the Y
and Y hats
yeah so uh
so of course the the knife answer is one
could encode it as Boolean but of course
that doesn't work so even if you go from
the Boolean to the finite domain the you
know the synthesizing one output itself
is not as easy
here I could just synthesize it
I mean
we basically said I can very efficiently
synthesize one output and then I can
reduce the multi-output case to the one
output case
but if I say that this one output can
take on
let's say whatever thousand values uh
I don't have such simple forms
for coming up to the schooling function
from that one output
so particularly uh
I mean for example if I take a bit
Vector right so white bit Vector okay so
and then if I'm talking about a
permutation right I take an input bit
vector and it gives some properties of a
permutation which gives me an output bit
vector
finding out that permutation
is not easy
even for a single output good thanks one
just one question then your tie to qpf
not dqbf right so your schooling
function is always a function of all X
cut all the Y's depends on all the X's
as opposed to dqpf sum of the X's yes
and that does your
does your knowledge representation
depend intimately on the two qbf
or does it work can you make it work for
for the dqbf thing can we can you make
it work for 2D qpf
or is it fundamentally what would that
mean is is the knowledge representation
is that fundamentally tied to that all
the Y's depend on all the X's or are you
able to
yeah so this one is uh tied to uh the
two qbf every output can depend on all
the inputs
so we have been doing some work on uh
not trying to come up with a
representation for dqbf
but uh
I think there has been work basically
you can take a dqbf uh specification and
you can extract some
uh
specifications on only the dependent
sets and then you can probably try to
apply this and then try to lift it but
it's not a direct representation
so I mean you can solve a dqbf problem
by projecting onto the dependent sets
and then correcting them later on
dqbf is a much harder problem right it's
let's be complete
so so this representation uh does not
work for dqba I mean it does not
directly give you
you have a heavy Hammer so the question
is really how heavy is the hammer parts
yeah so uh I mean we tried but we failed
maybe there is a way to do knowledge
compilation for dqbf as well we tried
using this but we could not
there was there was an obvious way to do
this
yeah the question that's probably
similar to everyone just asked are there
any natural synthesis problems that
involve more than two alternations of
quantifiers for Rolex there exist why
for all we see there exists W because
some of these methods may not work if
the output you would like to do the
first block and then pass it next
natural synthesis problems that you hear
these alternations yeah I mean uh turn
based games yes so how do you handle
them iteratively or it's another method
for us
so uh
so so so
it's still qbf it's not bqbf but you
have a linear ordering among the
dependencies right
every existential variable can depend on
all the universal variables to the left
of it so it turns out that this can be
adapted to that setting
without worrying about how how your
output looks in terms of the input I
mean no we have I mean it's not directly
applicable but this can be used to solve
basically what we are saying is that
uh there's a linear ordering among the
dependent sets right and so uh
at least one very simple way to do it
would be to
treat all the existential variables to
the left of right so you have let's say
exist for all exists
if I treat the first block of pharah
exists also as for all
right because we are allowing
unrealizable things so it's perfectly
possible that for some of those
valuations there is right sometimes
excess X for all y exists said
and if I treat it as frolics for all Y
axis said then I can express Z in terms
of X and Y
and it's okay that for some of these X's
there may not be any said right but then
I can substitute that and then produce
so so this would be
you know the very
base level algorithm and then there are
certain optimizations you can do on top
of it
sure
there's no more questions I guess we can
thank you again
[Applause]
okay